each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello good afternoon and thank you all
for coming my name is Mike Zukowski and
I'm a program manager in the external
research group in Microsoft and I have
the pleasure of introducing singing tois
who is an intern in our group this
summer and she is studying at the
queensland university of technology
majoring in or getting her PhD in
bioinformatics and she's joined us this
summer to work on a project called Geno
zoom i'll let her describe the project
in detail and if there are follow-up
questions after this event or if you
wish to contact singhi later about this
this effort her contact information is
actually included in the about dialog
box of this application so without
further ado I'd like to introduce
singing thank you very much for the
intro Mike so like to first thank you
for joining me at the presentation so
I'll just go on ahead um so the name of
the project was Gino's room I do have
quite a few slides and they do cover a
lot of content but that was mainly
because the slides will be put up with
the application itself but I won't
necessarily go into every single point
just a quick overview so what was
motivation behind this project so
currently there are actually a lot of
many publicly available genome browsers
out there online and we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel but we did notice
that a few things of the current
browsers so they don't really scale well
to the data they don't provide seamless
user experience when you're going from
low to high resolutions rapidly it's
difficult to view your own sequence data
in the application so for example the
UCSC genome browser which is probably
the most popular browser out there to
view your own roof and genome sequence
you would have to actually download the
source code and then set it up yourself
and it's quite difficult for a
non-unique
but and then they don't really support
unformatted use their annotations so
you'll get to see a bit of that in my
demo later on so the proposed solution
for the project was to investigate how
deep zoom and Silverlight would be able
to address some of these issues and make
the user experience much more seamless
and smooth so why deep zoom or ok and
also known as Saul dragon so basically
it was because it provided a nice way to
navigate large-scale data and it
optimized bandwidth and it did this by
creating a image pyramid of your high
resolution image data and it only
downloads the tiles that you are viewing
so further advantages of actually using
deep zoom and applying it to the genome
space is that it takes care of the data
sampling for you because it already
creates that image pyramid with the
preprocessed images the user can pretty
much do select the region of interest
that they're interested in so just jump
straight into the middle of the genome
without downloading the entire file
again and then with the different images
created as different collections you
have the potential to mix and match and
create your own Geno zoom collection so
in the beginning it all sounded very
cool very nice but along the way though
I did notice some limitations so the
major limitation of deep zoom applying
it to a gene and browsing domain was
that deep zoom is primarily designed for
images that sort of go with the
traditional for 369 aspect ratios so it
didn't lend itself well to the gene
conventional genome images which are
really long and thin so this is an
example of a DNA sequence so the demo
that i'll be demonstrating is actually
showing the e coli genome so it's a
bacterium that lives in the gut that one
for a bacterium
it's about four and a half million base
pairs so for another half million
characters at four pixels per base pair
we're looking at a really long image and
only at eight pixels high it's really
long and thin so the problem with using
deep zoom in this case is that when you
zoom out to have a view of the entire
genome that line is pretty much
invisible you don't see it I tried
compensating by increasing the height so
that when you're zoomed out you could
still see images but that has a
performance hit when you're generating
the images and it's pretty much wasted
space because everything vertically is
the same so the reason for this obstacle
was primarily because of the way deep
zoom works when you're zooming into an
image it actually stretches the image
horizontally and vertically whereas the
desired behavior for a genome browser is
just to move horizontally so what I've
got is an animation to demonstrate what
I mean so this is your low resolution
image at the top there level in and then
you get a high resolution here and then
mm plus 2 so what happens in deep zoom
is when you zoom in at n you're actually
stretching horizontally and vertically
and then it replaces the tiles from
higher resolution and then again and
you're replacing the tiles from the next
zoom level so that's the actual behavior
the desired behavior for browser would
be at each room level the height of the
image is actually the same and what
happens is when you zoom in the only
stretches image horizontally and their
replaces two tiles so I tried different
ways to work around that find out what I
could do with images how I couldn't play
with them just to get around that
zooming obstacle so one of the trials
was I have just a single hosting control
and then I dynamically lay out all the
images at runtime so specify where each
of the collection of
images go so at the top there we've got
the entire ecology gnome so it's called
a gene density track so the blue lines
are showing genes in the forward
direction and the black lines are
showing genes in the reverse direction
so what the red boxes are meaning is if
you zoom into a region there you get
sort of more information coming up the
deeper you go so we go down to actual
gene blocks with arrows pointing in the
direction you get a associated graph
information keep going down and
eventually get to the DNA sequence but
the problem with this approach is that
you sort of lose contact you can't see
all that information in one go at that
resolution so you lose what happened to
the peaks of the graphs so that was one
problem the next attempt that I did was
actually go into the individual zoom
layer of deep zoom image tiles and
manually tweak those image tiles so
change the sort of height at different
zoom levels so zoom levels denoted by
the numbers but what we notice in here
is that the zooming action is no longer
seamless you get this sort of
transparency happening and a popping
type effect and it just doesn't look
really nice when you're zooming in and
things I like popping out at you and
then there was a came across an approach
called dynamic deep zoo so what this one
was instead of having all your image
tiles preprocess and hosted on the
server what happens is generally the MSI
which is the multi scale image control
in Silverlight that hosts the deep zoom
images whenever you do man pan it
actually hits HTTP request to the server
and it comes back with image tiles so
instead of that we intercept the HTTP
requests write our own handler that
generates the images on the flight and
then send those tiles back so the
classic example is the mandal Mandelbrot
plot so that one is actually when you
zoom in its recalculating what you see
and then popping up the patterns and I
think this is a possible solution to the
problem and it's worthwhile in further
investigation the only thing I couldn't
go further with it for the project was
because it requires the database back
and to store all the genomic data and
pretty much I was sort of weighing up
doing that in time with the internship
itself so the proposed approach for our
genome zoom was we arrived at a three
component based view so I've got a
navigation view at the top that shows
the entire genome and it's a static
image a region view which is a zoom in
location and then a details view which
goes down to the base pair level and
I'll go into more depth in the demo so
just quickly before the demo sort of
tossing out reasons why I selected
Silverlight over WPF for this project
basically because the selection of using
deep zoom in Silverlight we have the
multi scale image control which is not
supported in WPF so if I went with WPF I
would have to re-implement all the
animations with zooming and panning and
then actually have to handle data
sampling as well
and then with silverlight it's
accessible by web so that makes it
really easy for sine biologists to share
their research and it also has out of
browser option which so you can download
it onto your desktop and still interact
with the application but with
silverlight there was a few
disadvantages primarily i couldn't use
mbf library to pass my data file to
generate the image the raw images that's
required by deep zoom and image loading
is dependent on network so hopefully we
won't see that in the demo but sometimes
the image tiles freezes so it stays
blurry and we serve like you cannot
access the local file system but there
is a workaround which is to host the
images on your local machine and it
still works n-never dude oh look at the
demo okay so this is geno zone so the
top layer is the navigation view
actually i'll use the mouse is you so
what I'm showing here is the e.coli Gino
which is the bacterium in our gut so the
top layer is the navigation view which
shows the entire genome blue showing
genes in the forward direction and then
black strap showing genes in the reverse
direction it's not very interesting
because in bacteria they're small and
pretty much the entire genome is
contained functional information so if
it was showing humans you have a sparser
diagram in the region the red box in the
navigation you here corresponds to what
we see in the region view so that's from
one to twenty five thousand and then the
RIP box in the region view there
corresponds to the details view so most
of the interaction and action
happens in these two components here so
what i can do is pretty much just
dragged to a random location of
interests and this region and detail
will correspond so this is something
that the current genome browsers lack
with that seamless sort of interaction
when you dragged to a random region you
have sort of a loading screen not that
smooth at animation that's happening so
let's see what's down to the details so
i can get actual DNA bases I don't care
about the first track I'll move that way
so in the genome zoom it supports
unformatted user annotations so what
that means is you pretty much put it a
post-it note type information so i can
change the coloring of that and it pops
up and i can edit or delete that if I
wish what I can also do is such genes an
e.coli please be kind there we go so
let's have a look at that one it's
related to toxin
so again i can add another push pin and
i can also search my annotations similar
to what i did with searching a gene now
to simplify sort of sorry not to
simplify what you can also do is
configure the tracks so you can turn
them on and off and you can also add in
your own custom data so if you have some
that are already processed
it will come up but they do have to be
hosted either on a local machine or
somewhere on the web server but as long
as you have that HTTP URL you can add
that into there now one example of how
genome zoom with that horizontal and
vertical and sorry just let me restart
so while we wait basically what I was
going to mention is demo2 you what
happens with the horizontal and vertical
zooming action if you have graphs with
peaks and troughs when you keep zooming
in the peaks and troughs pretty much
clip so I was trying to find different
ways of visualizing that sort of data
but still keep be able to sort of know
what values are associated with that
location excuse me
I was actually having trouble with the
server this morning so
sorry
yeah it's actually on
dmz
okay I just leave it and move on so this
was one of the issues that we noted that
with deep zoom you can have the image
freezing up on you one of the reasons
why this was happening was because deep
zone was set up to avoid possible do s
attacks so if it's if you do a lot of
zooming around and panning that sort of
thing it sort of just stops you and
stops the images from downloading so
unfortunately that is happening right
now but I'll move on so the other thing
is that you can pretty much install the
application on the desktop and if you
had the net connection you can do all
the interactions that i was showing in
the browser
okay um that's all so I created a tool
the GZ so it's a genome zoom image
generator basically it's just a tool to
convert the gem banked file file put it
through the mbf library deposit and
generate the raw image data which then
put through the deep zoom tools to
create the image permits okay some of
the knowing issues with the application
the image generation can be slow but if
you have reference data they don't they
don't change that often so once you
create it for the reference data it's
not too big of an issue data storage can
be a problem because i'm creating
turning text pretty much into large
image directories but with the dynamic
deep zoom i was mentioning before with
the database database back in on the
server this could potentially solve that
problem multiple mouse events before the
animation has caught up I've seen can
have unpredicted behavior with the
locations and then with the details and
range slider so the red windows and your
other views sometimes the
synchronization behavior there is a bit
unexpected as well because of sort of
where is this input source coming from a
few sort of disadvantages using deep
zoom in a genome browser is I can't
dynamically change visuals so what I
mean by that is i can't select so for a
group of genes and change the color of
their genes because I'm dealing with
static images the custom data must be
hosted by a web server which I mentioned
I guess in this case if there is a multi
scale image control in WPF that may
solve that problem and the data size
explosion from text to images is also
another issue but with images you could
potentially display much more
information than you get in the text so
it's sort of weighing a trade-off there
performance is limited by the network
connections and that again if the images
were on a local host that performance
itself could be faster okay but the
advantages it is it does produce a
smoother user experience what I should
do is actually demonstrate one of the
other genome browsers that are currently
out there at the moment if you're
interested I'll be happy to do that
after you do get a quick navigation from
low to high res resolution and with the
tagging it supports unformatted user
annotation so what that means is
basically you don't have to conform to
what the service requires you can just
put in push pins or post-it note type
tags and I have the intention of
converting those tags into sort of
tracks so you can save them and then
upload them for future use it's easier
for the user to view their own data so
they don't need to actually download
that and set up their own service as
long as they've got the data converted
into the image permit and they can just
get a URL and then put it into the
application itself and that sort of
lends itself to having a potential of
the user to create their own sort of
genome zoom collection so if they're
happy with all these different tracks
and different information they can put
them together and then save it and
because i'm dealing with images the
application itself is sort of in a blunt
way of putting it it's dumb to what it's
hosting its just sort of images so
potentially you can generate any sort of
image you want as long as they line up
to a genome data location coordinate and
I've got a whole list of future work but
I'll just concentrate on a few the first
one is I would really like to look at
creating this using a dynamic approach
and using the database in the back end
to see how it would solve some of the
issues that I mentioned previously an
integration with pivot that was actually
on the agenda but we just ran out of
time
and linking to external sources so hold
this up there and the last one is
actually I would like to compare the
performance of this compared to late a
pure silver light orb WPF version
actually drawing all those features
every time you zoom in pan so just to
see what the effects are there and to
close off just like to say a special
thank you to my mentor Mike Symon Bob
and bits who I worked really closely
throughout the summer and gave me
feedback for the project which I really
appreciate and a whole lot of other
teams that helped make this happen sort
of dangerous putting a thank you slide
this yeah if you don't find your name up
there thank you and lastly I like to
thank you as well for turning up for the
presentation really appreciate that and
questions
I saw that we would search you can
search on something like toxin which
would imply that somebody are identified
its purpose but what if I wanted to go
look for some palindromic sequential I
found some other bacteria can actually
I'm not in the prototype version the
sort of issue with that is because I'm
actual as I previously said the gene and
i'll zoom itself sort of done because
only hosting static images if I wanted
to do that i would also have to send the
underlying base pair sequence but if i
did that it could essentially do that or
you could sort of do all the searches
using external tools that mean or sort
of pattern recognition tools sorry don't
go to start yes yes and then you can
upload that information as a track
outside the microprocessor yeah sorry i
should mention that the intention is
this will be open source and it will be
put onto codeplex so the source code
will be available and you can download
it I the website that I was working from
is actually mbf server I it might be a
temporarily we haven't worked out if
it's going to be hosted somewhere yet
that's going to be I'm going to talk to
my mentor after that
we'll end up keeping it there minimum so
the people outside microsoft access
demo
will be a document as well
yes so there'll be a technical document
which goes more into sort of the classes
and structures in all that stuff yeah
more on the problems you had with image
generation because i have the same
problem leave the D to administer
generation how long it takes because
obviously I think a lot of us have those
problems what kind of possibilities are
there that night fell today um okay so
with imagery generation my sort of
bottleneck was actually producing the
raw images that would feed in as input
into deep zoom itself so it wasn't
actually deep zoom making the pyramids
that was all right but it was actually
generating four and a half billion
characters and then all that so i was
looking at 1,500 images and then for
each track I was looking at 1,500 images
and in those were the bottlenecks so
different ways of trying to do that was
paralyzing the code it I think it
depends on depending on your underlying
structure at times it saved me time and
saved so in improved in performance but
at other times because it was a
contingent contiguous block I needed to
know what images were in my previous
block so I couldn't do that in parallel
but I think that just needs a rewrite of
the code itself
so have anybody in the debate room look
at this is he does is it significantly
better than the ideas and transitions
animations help people maintain context
from their browsing or what other
feedback and we had a chance to get from
anybody back in um so short answer no
longer answer earlier sort of meat mid
internship I was doing the user
experience studies at that time I had a
very very early prototype version of the
genome zoom and I had sort of handed out
to people to see get their reaction one
person sort of like the whole animation
smooth navigation so that was a positive
feedback but I think generally we didn't
see that many people and generally it
just really depends on what they were
working on because the trend is that the
biologists tend to stay within a
specific zoom level they don't really go
from all the way from a genome down to
the DNA they tend to sort of go either
the top to sort of the navigation in the
region view or the region view in the
details view so yeah I think need more
sort of user feedback on that and then
the other suppose I did send a link to
decrement so I'm hoping to get some
feedback from him as well
do you think this will scale too yes
because basically you're just doing
images so I'm thinking theoretically it
should just scale the only issue human
is you're going to have to spend
probably a day to produce those images
yes and storage actually that's going to
be an issue so an example of storage was
that you call a genbank file is only 13
Meg's those image pyramids came out to
be 12 gigs so yeah so yes so that's sort
of why I'm sort of really looking
forward to doing that dynamic deep zoom
approach to see what would happen there
but again as I mentioned in images you
can potentially put in a lot more
information in there than what is in a
normal sort of djembe file so I could
for example color code my jeans based on
function or cog categories or sort of
different domains that sort of things
and that's still a single image but I've
got a lot more information in that
single image than the normal text based
sauce
no other questions okay oh so outside of
research purposes as soon as we use for
anything else and so one of the thoughts
throughout the internship was actually
this could lend itself to an education
domain so something like the Chronos
room I'm not sure if you're familiar
with the queen of zoom but basically yet
it might lend itself well to the
education domain so in that scenario one
could do maybe a cooked up tutorial that
goes out from if you want to aim it at
high school level or a sort of undergrad
level so it cooks up from you know your
this is your entire organism let's
concentrate on maybe a dystrophin gene
so it causes some certain diseases and
it goes down to maybe the protein level
these are the domains that we're
interested in mutations in the DNA
causes this sort of diseases that sort
of thing so it goes down straight down
to the DNA level so that type of
tutorial Mesut for this type of
application okay no other questions then
thank you very much